yeah has there been a producer because
you know a lot of people don't know this
about you you're kind of like a what I
would consider to be a quite the hip-hop
head yeah for sure you love you some Jay
Dilla yeah you know what I'm saying uh
there's been guys like Mad Lib who've
been pretty active recently like putting
out great records but like has got mad
libs number I don't I don't think
anybody does that's what that's one guy
I've been wanting to work with from the
beginning that I haven't got a chance to
I never really came across bro so I
don't think anyone's coming holler at me
bro if you hear this [ __ ] I was gonna
say that's somebody who you'd like to
work with I would love to work with Mad
Lib I recently just did an interview
with Talib kwali and we supposed to do
something he's also a legend to me and
someone always wanted to work with so
I love that type of music for sure I
don't think people would put that like
together because I mean you've done some
records anybody that's a real Thai fan
with no like back from tying Corey days
all the way up to now and even like if
that that one-off I dropped with J Cole
like if you hear that you would know
that's like that's my type of [ __ ] yeah
Mad Lib we got to make it happen
he's out there he's just he's making I
already made um all uh the uh [ __ ] uh
bandana [ __ ] the Freddy good job I heard
he made that [ __ ] off his iPad
yeah man he a boy